this video is sponsored by ridgewallet
so is the most enchanting arc of one
piece i've read through and
i've enjoyed my time reading this arc
more than practically every single setup
arc in the series
i'm serious it's immersive captivating
thrilling and it succeeds in
establishing situations and lore
that have made me even more interested
in and excited for what's to come in
this story i get the feeling that zou
might not be held in super high standing
amidst the rest of the one piece catalog
specifically because i've heard no one
talk about this 22 chapter long prologue
to this massive
oncoming section of the story curiously
titled the four
emperor saga i honestly can't wait to
get into why i love this act to a
borderline unreasonable extent
so without further ado i'm totally not
mark and these are my first impressions
of thoughts on
and review for the magical the
mysterious
and the magnificent zo arc
[Music]
so right off the bat the most enjoyable
aspects from this arc come from how it's
structured
expertly interweaved with the prior
dressrosa arc the events of which
informed the beginning and consequences
of this one we are tied to the
perspective of the fractured straw hat
pirates under luffy
whom after defeating and handing over
doflamingo to the navy
is now in search of his friends on the
island of zou after they attempted to
escape from big mom the stakes tensions
and questions this story establishes for
its readers to come to grips with
right from the get-go are palpable and
massively captivating this feels like a
genuine
and true continuation of the story
helped inextricably by the fact so much
of what has made the ark feel visceral
was set up in the ark prior
which while relatively rudimentary
compared to how advanced some of the
steps he's taken in the story so far
have been the fact remains that simple
and basic additions to the story like
this help in a multitude of ways to not
only help the pacing of the prior arc by
cutting down
focusing the cash you need to occupy but
it also encourages the very prior arc in
dressrosa to carry a lot of the heavy
lifting for this
one by establishing tension and a goal
for us to follow and this is super
simple stuff in principle but
when you're dealing with the climax of
the biggest arc in a long
time it's reassuring to know that oda is
always thinking about the future no
matter how complicated the current
circumstances are
which is something i cannot say about
other properties that toei represent
like dragon ball super which while i did
enjoy aspects of it to a huge extent
really had very little linking its story
arcs together causing them to feel like
isolated standalone narrative instances
instead of connecting ones as part of a
greater story like one piece effectively
accomplishes
time and time again in any case this is
what i loved about the setup for zoe as
an arc but how did i enjoy the ark
itself
it's a delicious arc that left me hungry
for so much more
which is exactly what i want from every
arc i read through it's exciting concise
and does not overstay its welcome like
others may or may not have in the past
and this arc i would identify as being
easily broken up into three separate
components that ultimately serve to make
this story as interesting and well-paced
as it was
so let's go through each section and try
to identify where its strengths lie and
how it implemented them in such an
effective way kicking things off with
part one
the unknown and the mysterious occupying
the contents of this very first section
of the story is a distinct feeling of
mystery and caution already as i
mentioned a moment ago it's been
established what the goal of the straw
hats currently is
and that's to regroup before making
their next move however we are only at
this point made aware of the
circumstances surrounding luffy's group
on their way to rendezvous
with the rest of his crew and due to one
piece being the story of luffy
this arc offers a unique circumstance
wherein we know exactly the same
info luffy does and because he doesn't
know where the rest of them are
nor what sort of fate have befallen them
like did they make it to the island of
zou did they get captured by big mom or
did something else happen to them that
we aren't aware of yet
these are all questions swirling around
in luffy's mind and by extension
us linking us to the story in a very
visceral way
assessing the possible outcomes as the
story presses forward and as this story
highlighted during the initial voyage to
zou
it reinforces what we are voyaging for
the missing straw hats with nami not
being there to navigate leading to
various navigation tribulations
and with sanji gun luffy tries his hand
and fails at whipping up some grub
for his team these are small inclusions
in the story but just like amazon lily
demonstrated luffy lacking in certain
areas his friends helped him with
so too does this arc demonstrate the
struggles they face when they aren't all
united proving in addition to the
emotional reasoning we have to find a
regroup with the rest of them they add a
utilitarian one they need each other to
survive
in addition to those reinforcements of
the established themes in this arc we're
also greeted by some really interesting
fallout and points
of view from various characters dragon
expresses that he wants to gather all
the revolutionary leaders and seems to
show more interest in robin
than his own son which i call bs on
seeing as
he saw to his son's safety in low town
don't think i forgot about
that mister i can control the weather or
something vaguely like that
but that's not what's curious about this
scene in fact it's the instance that
blackbeard seems to have the location of
this revolutionary base
targeting it as something in need of
overthrowing which i'm exceedingly
excited for considering i've been
waiting for dragon to do something for
ages he's shown in low town we see a
glimpse of his picture in alabasta
and really he's peppered throughout this
tale but never
ever the focus so i'm interested to see
where this plot line goes
and finally before i move on it's
briefly mentioned that there exists this
big individual while
being encouraged by his mother who
claims to be the supposed son of
whitebeard
so yeah don't know what to make of that
these side stories are really the only
instances
in this arc that draw our attention away
from the main plot which
i'm honestly thrilled about because this
happens when they discover and arrive at
zou
and man was i not prepared for what i
saw
this reveal with it being a combination
of both awe and astonishment
created within me a feeling i can
honestly say i not for a second
anticipated or saw coming for me this is
the single greatest reveal spectacle
of the entire series bar none and i mean
that the surge of questions curiosity
and the notion that we're gonna climb
that thing was needless to say enough to
spur out my desire to explore this world
and uncover
its secrets that bit more we were
looking for an island called zou
and what we discovered was a land mass
carried on the back of the
single largest creature ever shown to us
in this series
a 1 000 year old elephant as it marches
dead across its world where is it going
why is it walking how did zoe get on top
of this elephant what
is on top of this elephant all these
questions swirled aggressively in my
head creating a beautiful cocktail of
curiosity and
intrigue needless to say i adored how
the story was structured
but now i adore how it's framed but the
first question is how in the hell are
they going to climb this thing well
a certain samurai with an incredibly
helpful power has a proposal
nobody knew
this was one of the single strangest but
best gag sequences that i've probably
ever experienced in one piece i have no
idea how it's structured in the anime
but in the manga the journey this
little cartoon dragon character goes on
to get the crew to the top of this
massive elephant is framed in a very
short period of time as an inspirational
journey that's even structured like its
very own hero's
journey it's so over the top and funny
he accepts the call to action
he struggles endures loss even pushes
through for the sake of the others
and proves himself wrong at the end
rising to the occasion in summiting the
massive hind leg of this elephant before
disappearing
entirely it's so ridiculous and i love
oda for creating something so
wacky to lighten the mood before we
discover even more mystery on this
island
what's more is that at this point in the
story i had a theory brewing which
proved to be wrong but i'll tell you
anyway so the straw hats in addition to
looking for the rest of the crew here
came to this island in the first place
to retrieve the third and final part of
the samurai group
a ninja called rhizo now no description
is given about this character and
when the two samurai fall off the
elephant they do so after a monkey fell
from the island towards them for the
longest time i was convinced that this
little monkey guy could have been the
ninja rhizo
but it wasn't it was just a monkey what
an appalling prediction
everything about this journey feels like
an adventure in its purest form the
likes of which i haven't felt since the
group's excursion into the lands of
skypia
and to be clear i think this works
better because we already have the
driving motivation alongside the
exploration
zou is lush and gorgeous with the panels
of the manga demonstrating this fact at
every available opportunity but
curiously once luffy races off on his
own in excitement
robin remarks that there are clear signs
of a struggle saying that who never
lived here
their civilization looks as though it
came to an abrupt end two weeks ago
and i just love robin's deductive
reasoning in this section looking around
at all the architecture inferring from
its construction that this was man-made
and that they lived here for a very long
time made abundantly true when the
elephant
itself spouts water onto its back which
in turn gives life to the entire
area but also causes them significant
stress because they weren't really
anticipating that it's small
inclusions like this that honestly give
believability to the world of zou of
course it needs water to survive
and of course the elephant will always
need to cool itself off and it's those
admittedly brief moments of detail that
adds so much to this world
and once we discover the inhabitants of
this island we learn that any and every
anthropomorphic creature we've ever met
in the show more than likely originated
from this small land on the back of this
elephant
that includes the bear from law's crew
again like any good addition to this
sprawling story it enriches the prior
stories
with extra insight and information in
addition to that
we also meet carrot and it's this
introduction guided by this
dog person called wanda who's supposedly
wearing nami's clothes
she leads luffy too and eventually the
rest of the straw hats to their base of
operations within this world
where they regroup with nami chopper and
brook but
one person is curiously missing sanji
so where is he and this instance when
the crew finally meet up with
and reconvene with each other is where
the first section of the story ends and
admittedly at this point
i had a ton of questions but thankfully
the next section did exactly what i
wanted it to do
it went back in time and showed us what
transpired right after we left off with
the crew as they were being pursued by
big mom's ship
during dressrosa i was massively excited
to say the least specifically because i
thought the sequence called for a moment
like this but also because i was really
interested to see how oda would tell a
sort of story like this
so let's check out how this story came
together and filled in the holes in the
plot
section two filling in the timeline from
this point in the story there will be
nothing but revelation after revelation
bringing us all up to speed with the
events that have transpired since we
last saw
sanji's group 11 days ago in the story
interestingly they actually escaped the
clutches of big mom's ship without much
effort with caesar in tow also
which reminds me sanji and caesar are
gone and with it only taking an extra
day after they do lose big mom's ship
to arrive at the base of this enormous
elephant carrying
zou now what's interesting about this
whole encounter to follow is
not only the curious characters and
circumstances they uncover but
more so the fact that this timeline
conflicts with robin's remark earlier
about the city coming into conflict over
two weeks prior
and naturally nami's story corroborates
this fact
something happened before even sanji's
group arrived
and all the while this tale is being
recounted by nami in the back of our
minds we have the single piece of
information we are waiting to learn
about
and that's sanji's disappearance now
naturally there are a host of other
questions the gang are looking to learn
and slowly over the course of this
explanation from nami we learned the
harsh and uncomfortable fate that befell
the poor civilization almost three weeks
prior
at the hands of one of kaido's main men
master jack
the design of this person is massively
intimidating and with a bounty of
1 billion berries it really puts into
perspective the magnitude of a threat
this individual
boasts and despite the forces of the
daytime and nighttime on this island not
cooperating they do provide a decent
struggle against this particular foe
but perhaps the most interesting part is
the reason this master jack of kaido's
empire has chosen to ransack the island
in the first place
they are looking for rhizo from wano
again i'm completely unaware of how this
particular grouping of scenes plays out
in the anime but in the manga the
visuals depict a truly harrowing
circumstance after befalling the likes
of the two leaders duke dog storm and
cat viper alongside their many people
declaring and pleading with their
torturers that they do not know of nor
have they
ever harboured any such individual in
the face of this
maybe because they don't believe them or
maybe because they just like it
the forces of master jack insist on
dragging the poor inhabitants of this
country kicking and screaming to near
death
it's horrific we're also introduced to a
bunch of other characters working
under master jack including but not
limited to a certain individual called
sheep's head
he's not a very nice guy after many days
of this torture out of
seemingly nowhere master jack was called
away on an urgent
need leaving just a skeleton crew behind
to finish them off
and this is where our straw hat sanji
nami brook chopper and momonosuke arrive
with caesar in tow
again every piece of information drip
thread throughout this story helps us
add context to
different visuals we were shown earlier
in the arc when luffy and them
arrived we've seen the ruined structures
we've seen the racks where people were
left to die on we've seen
every wound this damaged civilization
has endured and now
we have an appropriate context for
everything and what's more is that the
events that took place
in the last arc totally informed the
events of this one
down to a t and i absolutely adore that
it might not
seem like a huge issue when thrown out
quickly but something one piece has
usually been really good at is avoiding
convenience when it comes to the events
the characters participate in
for me the sign of a weaker writer or
weak story structure is one that has
their characters arrive at a location
where
as luck would have it something out of
the ordinary for that particular village
or town is happening or
maybe a random chance event lures them
in a good example of this plot
orientation in action can be observed in
series that typically adopt the monster
of the week type format they might have
a loose
overarching plot but it's by no means
the focus of every given episode in
these
characters encounter fantastical things
within each place they visit
and this sort of causes the characters
to feel more like
passive participants in the world while
other more active or interesting ones
inform the events that unfold admittedly
this is the preference i have
and there's nothing wrong with liking
that format but i love characters that
are active within their own story i love
individuals that once they enter a room
become the focus because
they are causing the interesting things
to happen they deserve this story to be
told about them this is why
vegeta during the saiyan anomic arcs was
so interesting and why i adore luffy how
many times have i described a scene
where luffy pretty much
just wings it or decides to randomly go
on the offense he doesn't wait for the
story to happen to
him luffy happens to the story and as
consistent as ever
luffy happens to this island too you see
once he defeated doflamingo
kaido suddenly became aware of it and
because he had that skin in the game
needing doflamingo he ordered master
jack someone he could trust
to leave whatever he was doing on zou
and pursue to free
doflamingo from his naval escort the
events of dressrosa not only set up this
arc
but this arc simply put couldn't have
existed
without it it is in the purest sense
inextricably linked with the events of
dressrosa with as i mentioned it's set
up being informed by it
and quite literally all of what makes
this arc interesting in a narrative
sense
spawns from that arc also the mystery
and the stakes would not even remotely
be at the same ballpark level had it not
been for the last installment and
because of this upheaval and leaving on
behalf of master jack
once the first group of straw hats did
arrive they were able to liberate the
people of zou from their torturers in
addition to providing the necessary aid
and because they provided aid
when luffy arrived with his crew they
were treated like heroes
this informs that and that informs this
everything is connected
everything makes sense and now we have
delicious context for it all i
love this arc everything just connects
perfectly and the simple addition of it
shows the far-reaching implications of
the actions the crew are taking these
days
no longer confined to the east blue or
the naval dominated section of the grand
line
we are in the new world now and when you
interfere with the business of an
emperor of the sea
the effects on the wider world can be
felt almost immediately
case in point zou in addition to that we
got some nice teamwork during these
flashbacks as sanji takes out the brutes
but still
the weapons used to win this struggle
over the minks of zou were gas based
and creations of caesar himself so good
thing he's there and just sucks up
everything
however still even with all the context
we are still missing crucial information
concerning the whereabouts of sanji
and this scene covers just that
um this is the scene that
pretty much dictates and will inform the
series of events that'll no doubt unfold
within the next coming arcs
and perhaps even further beyond i have
no idea if the effects are still being
felt today
of this scene but only time will tell
regardless and irrespective of future
complications this scene in this arc
creates a powerful moment for sanji
which
i'm honestly happy about
this video is brought to you by
ridge.com tnm
most people are still using wallets
designed in the 1990s and
in this modern landscape it's seriously
outdated and i should know i've been
using the same wallet since i was 15
years old and that means i've been using
some
outdated wallet for the last 14 years of
my life
in the same way phones have gotten more
practical and compact over the last few
decades so too of wallets and
it's honestly made a massive difference
to my pockets personally i hate having
cumbersome items in there and this
totally fits my new lifestyle
it holds up to 12 separate cards plus
room for cash and there's over 30
different colors and styles including
carbon fiber and burnt titanium to
choose from
and if that wasn't enough to win you
over yet check out their thirty
000 5 star reviews the durable nature of
each of these wallets comes with a
lifetime warranty so
in theory you could buy this one wallet
and carry it for life and the rich team
have told me that they're so confident
that you like it that they'll actually
let you test drive it for 45 days
that means you can send it back for a
full refund if it's not up to your own
standards
right now there's a special offer going
where you can get 10 off with
free worldwide shipping and returns and
you can get all of this by going to
ridge.com
tnm and using the coupon code tnm
link is in the description how about a
cup of tea for a change
i've got peppermint spearmint pickle tea
pepper tea and my favorite a pack of
peter piper pickled pepper tea
[Music]
as it happens two days prior to luffy
and the gang showing up on zou
big mom's forces appeared on the island
they announced that they are there for
two reasons but
interestingly the lion mink in their
company by the name of peacoms
one of the leaders in this group
declares his gratitude towards them for
saving his homeland from the rampaging
forces of kaido
citing that they will only take caesar
and not anything regarding their second
mission
and that's when this happens
[Music]
this is where the direct conflict within
the series of flashbacks takes root
capone benji another one of the in
command personnel and part of the worst
generation much the same as law and
luffy
takes the initiative by shooting peacoms
for his weak and overly sentimental
approach
getting in the way of why they were
there in the first place they are there
for two reasons the first is to retrieve
caesar which none of the straw hats have
any protest about but the second he'll
tell them once they step inside his body
wielding the power of the castle castle
fruit a portal opens into the ranks of
the internal fortress
and the group nervously sit around a
table this is when the news is finally
revealed and their second objective is
laid to bear
sanji i love this scene within it we
learn a tremendous amount regarding
sanji's upbringing and backstory in just
a few illuminating pieces of information
we learned that he's part of an
important crime family called the
vinsmokes of which he's the third
son interestingly i always figured he
was an orphan given the circumstances
surrounding his introduction to the
series with zeph and his backstory
therein
so to hear that his immediate family his
nuclear family are not only important
but
also alive is something i'm not even
sure i know how to reconcile yet
immediately i'm filled with service
level suspicions like there must have
been a good reason for him to leave
someone must have helped him leave i
mean he was very young child at the time
and during this arc a specific emphasis
has drawn on the distance he must have
traveled to get to the east blue from
where he was in the north
was it someone in the navy how did they
cross the red line i have so many
questions circulating in my head
surrounding this very small plot thread
that i'm dizzy from thinking about it
despite this dizzying news however sanji
is being beckoned for one specific
reason to marry the 35th daughter of big
mom
going by the name of pudding i have no
idea again what to make of this news or
what sort of far-reaching implications
might stem from this but all i do know
is that sanji demanded that his friends
be freed and in return he would go to
the tea party
being held by big mom sanji writes a
letter before taking his leave
promising to return having received such
important news regarding the fate of one
of the original four straw hats
this story once again pulls the rug out
from beneath my feet
[Music]
after the samurai revealed themselves to
be in allegiance with the rest of the
mink civilization
this insane piece of information is
revealed
tying up the end of this section in a
surprising but welcome
bow is the reveal of rhizo the samurai
they had initially arranged to go to zou
to retrieve in the first place
it's revealed that despite rhizo
actually being harbored on the island of
zou the inhabitants
not for a second entertained the idea of
ever selling them out to their torturers
which on its own is badass but they also
tied him up
and did everything in their power to
make sure that he was none the wiser of
their plight
it's honestly quite sad and adds a lot
of respect to the minks that live here
specifically when rizo talks about how
they brought him food and took care of
him despite their clearly worsening
conditions
as the days progressed it's a harrowing
tale and not to mention makes a great
little swerve when
also informing us of the alliance the
country has with wano
and with that that brings us to the
third and final part of this arc and
that is
reveals and conflict this is the section
where oda drops a
much welcomed and hefty exposition dump
i say welcomed because of a single piece
of information one dimensions towards
the beginning of this arc and that's
that this civilization has been atop
this elephant for a thousand years which
meant that it was perfectly within
reason for me to infer from that that
this civilization might have something
to do with the void century and would
you look at what the ninja is tied to
it's a ponoglyph but not just a regular
run-of-the-mill panoglyph it's a
redstone ponoglyph and these things are
bloody important
this is the first sign of an end goal or
a means with which to get the location
for an end goal
i have seen in the series you see this
special red poneglyph thing
is part of a four piece set each one
points to a specific location
in the world and if you plot all the
locations gathered by
all of these on a map and intersect the
coordinates you get the location
of raftel the reason why raftel is
important is because it was only
traveled to by the former king of the
pirates
and may also be the location of the
fabled one-piece
treasure so it's sort of a big deal not
just because it presents a clear and
easily understandable goal for us to
follow but
it also informs the rest of the story
from here on out because
once the situation with sanji gets
addressed they will have to try to
locate
and decipher the locations of all of
these redstone poneglyphs
which seems straightforward until you
come to understand that
two of these are in the possession of
big mom and
kaido respectively interestingly however
all the straw hats technically need to
do is to find the locations pointed to
on these maps
which sort of opens us up to lies in the
sea i mean what if luffy trusted someone
who told them that the panic lift was
pointing to a specific location
only to find out that it was a lie that
would totally throw off the location of
raftel and would make for some serious
tension between two characters and
that's just one way the story could go
with this particular line of thinking
and if you think this particular
revelation is the only thing mentioned
in this section then buckle up murosuke
isn't the son of kinemon
or any other samurai in the party for
that matter he is in fact a noble heir
by the name of
which explains his bratty attitude
further re-contextualizing prior events
but what's more is that i learned the
people of wano 800 years ago
created the poneglyphs which is of
course curious or obvious timing
depending on your definition considering
that that was when the void century
occurred
however more recently kaido and his
pirates are after invading wano and due
to their king not cooperating
they killed him we're talking about a
guy who apparently sailed with goldie
roger to raftel by the way
this is a huge deal apparently his dying
wish was to open one of those borders to
the rest of the world so i'm sure that
will play as a motivation in the future
but needless to say
this arc is amazing so now not only have
we a goal for the next arc which is to
suss out the situation with sanji and to
get him out of there
not only have we a goal after that in
dealing with the oppressive shoguns of
wano and liberating the country from
kaido
but we also have a separate overarching
b or c
plot where the straw hats need to
partake in the single most important
scavenger hunt
ever concocted it's bonkers and this arc
is still not done despite this being
short-lived and not really focused on
action at all with the main cast
it serves to bring yet again another
vital piece of information to the
forefront of my mind
master jack attempts to kill the
elephant that's carrying zou
and what's more is that he almost
succeeds in dealing some serious
damage to the poor creature too but
thankfully this happens
george stop bellowing through the skulls
of luffy and momo is the voice of the
giant elephant
and this situation is almost the exact
same as the one which occurred during
the fishman island arc with the princess
there
luffy can hear it but momo can hear it
and communicate to it
ordering it to take out master jack in
one of the most intimidating panels when
the elephant turns to face its attackers
something i thought worth mentioning
here is a subtle difference between the
neptunians and this massive elephant
that i've noticed the neptunians seem to
have their own
agency and this elephant needed the
order from momma
to me that's super interesting but i'm
not exactly even sure why yet and that's
really what this whole arc has been
it's ridiculously fascinating whether it
be the pursuit of kaido's men to hunt
down marco
which i never touched on by the way but
will definitely in a later part because
i'm sure it will come up later
carrot with all of her furry cuteness
opting to tag along with luffy in his
covert mission to whole cake island
alongside nami chopper brook and pedro
to save sanji
or the series of panels dedicated to
showing all the royal families around
the world redding themselves including
princess vivi by the way
for the reverie oh and uh master jack is
a fishman what and i didn't even mention
the base where the revolutionaries and
dragon work out of
has been completely toasted by
blackbeard long story short
so much is happening in this story i am
as i've mentioned countless times
throughout the duration of this video a
massive fan of the structure implemented
the opening establishes and invokes a
visceral sense of mystery the middle
deals with exploring and uncovering the
secrets introduced in that opening and
the final part extrapolates new and
fantastical ways with which to view the
world
with far-reaching implications for the
story moving forward to say that i
enjoyed this
would be an understatement of the
highest order in my opinion
this arc achieves a level of proficiency
and efficiency
all within a sufficient and succinct
amount of time
it's tightly paced it's exciting it's
exceptionally well written
it's got some shocking visuals and even
some of the best and most inventive
comedy i've seen in this series
the only setback i could see this arc
having for some people out there is the
level to which it abstains from the
typical fight scenes
now there are scuffles and fights to be
had in this arc just not with everyone
luffy being among those that don't
really take part in action during this
section
however that didn't bother me even in
the slightest
we had tons of fighting during dressrosa
it was time for a break in my opinion
and
zou was the perfect continuation while
not reaching the heights of this about
the archipelago arc in terms of tension
and action
i think it far exceeds it in practically
every other metric
making this for me a contender as one of
if not the best setup arc in the entire
one piece series
and i have no idea if that's a
controversial take but there it is
next week once again in an effort to
address as many things as i possibly can
and to not disappoint you guys i'll be
covering the first half of whole cake
island
but that'll do it for this video i'll
see you all next week on whole cake
island i've been tolding up mark and
thank you all so much for watching
[Music]